and there's a bit of a
shuffle around with the program uh
jeff foster's coming in at half-past one
louise fowler has changed to tomorrow so
no
you have been selected as first cab off
the rank post lunch please come up and
have a seat
uh thank you darren um i'd actually like
to stand up i cut
as long as the speaker picks you up and
you project sufficiently that's it
everybody's comfortable with me singing
yep
no objection
yeah that might be better uh
the breath of life
your worship counselors
community board member
pool committee chairman
southland district council staff and
members of public i pretty hot about a
subject
in blood and and i think it's something
that
council needs to take on board as a
responsibility
in the past it was a responsibility of
counsel
and i'm proposing that you take that
responsibility back
instead of passing it on to a committee
fine and dandy having a committee that
runs the pool down in blood
but the original responsibility of the
pool
i believe lies with the council and that
responsibility
lies towards the community in bluff
and i know there's been some fallacious
comments made
suggesting that icc doesn't care about
bluff
well i don't agree with those sentiments
i
i
actually think that um life is actually
well cared for
by icc i go to other suburbs in the city
and i see lots of things that um
they don't get that blood kits and like
we've got a
very very good um children's playground
there
that i'm aware of we were the first to
get the led lights and
yeah i can go at night and see the all
the stars so
i'm impressed the road's getting fixed
um lots of service is done so without a
doubt what i wanted to talk about was
um you should have had an adopt a
document from
crown minds provided to you
yeah and it talks about five-year
interest free loans
and and it pretty much suggests that
council would be eligible to get a loan
to tidy up the pool and keep it going
and and that's why i'm suggesting that
you
do the right thing and become
responsible for the pull
and that will also you know put asunder
that
assumption or that fallacious pork
that goes on in places which is like
gossip
suggesting that icc doesn't care
because i think you do care i think you
work very hard at what you do
counsellors and
mr mayor i think you do as well and mike
um i think you should be rewarded for
that
and respected for that so that's about
it from me
question kiera thanks noel um
initially through this process many
years ago
council uh went out to consultation with
the proposal to close the pool
and the bluff community came back with
the response of looking after it
themselves
you've raised through your submission
the opportunity for crown loans and i
mean that's not the only avenue that
council has for for raising
a loan obviously we're part of the lgfa
as well
the thing is the loan has to be repaid
so do you see that as
the repayment of the loan for this work
as something that could
be a targeted rate to fall on bluff
i think that's something to be debated
and decided
um maybe that's something that um we
could look at
into the future um to see whether um
there is a
targeted rate but at least it keeps
um a critical asset open
and blood and and i know that in bluff
it's something that the people
really care about and the council's
going to invest some money
in blood will be alone
um it's it's the pool that's one of the
things that's going to
really count um you know i mean we've
still got rubbish bins rusting away on
the street
that we can't replace because there's no
money but um people live with that
but i think the pool's really important
in fact
i see there's you know a lot more
elderly people starting to use it
and they'll also see um that there's a
well i guess you call a
um a new generation of young people
coming on in bluff
and and i uh i've always said and i
think i said in my
my comments that um
it's important that those young people
learn to swim
um in blood because it's a a port
it's a seaport and the chances are that
they're going to get a job on a
oyster boat or a fishing base or
something like that and like
you know someone that can't swim to
apparel um when they're at sea
so yeah i'd be open to that but i don't
say that that's um
a solution i i actually do think that
um it might be something that just comes
out of overall rates but
um yet to be decided and maybe the
community board and the council can talk
about that in the future
thanks noel councillors questions
councillor sopher thanks mr chair um no
just interested the idea of a
key entry to the pool do you think
that's going to
increase the usage oh yeah for sure and
like
um you know i'm not saying do away with
the committee
um and the committee's actually figured
that out themselves they can cut the
costs down
and also have that um well it would be
keyless entry it's the electronic entry
i think they're talking about
um you know sort of stepping into the
digital world and
the modern era and uh yeah i don't see a
problem with that
thank you other questions counselors
if not thank you for your passion now
for making a submission and coming along
and presenting to us this afternoon
thank you for your time
jeff
welcome along uh for those people who
weren't here this morning
um submitters you've got 10 minutes
there's the ding dong that comes at five
and another one at ten if you want us to
uh be able to ask questions uh try and
be finished before we get to the second
bell that would be awesome
you don't have to stand jeff please have
a seat um thanks thanks for your time um
yeah i'm jeff falst folstein the
principal at bluff school so i've been
um
part of the bluff community for just
over two years as the principal there
um yeah i put a submission in after
going to the pool meeting and some of
the people around here which are
doing a fabulous job in bluff and i
suppose for me
as supporting them um and our tamariki
um and actually being active and i think
um some really cool things going on in
bluff at the moment the use of the town
hall with um
the support from some of the people down
there getting our kids active and
for me i think having the pool there is
really crucial for
bluff and the community um what i've
seen in my short time in bluff
is the pool is a really strong part of
the community there's a lot of
traditional sports and bluff
uh swimming is one of them softball was
regenerated in bluff rugby's still
popping along all right um but swimming
is probably the one where they've got
the support of the locals and um
when it comes to swimming lessons we're
probably out of the sort of
ilt zone i suppose if you say it but um
so i mean we have a lot of dedicated
parents who come in and do swimming
lessons at our school
um and really for us we walk down the
road to the swimming pool and
if there's no pool there it's going to
be pretty hard work to come to
invercargill
you know i know other places do it but
i've just noticed coming from
originally was that lockheed was a
principal there and just noticing
without a pool there
the difference with the bluff kids is
they can swim really well
and probably what we're seeing now is
actually our kids who
do swimming lessons and there's a
there's a high percentage to them is
actually
they're starting to move through the
grades and some are actually getting up
to sort of almost
national level now with the squads in
town so they've had to move through that
but they started had to start somewhere
and bluff was the place so
and i've probably noticed one of our
kids it was a bit of a behaviour issue
because of his movement with his
swimming we've seen a real change with
him and that's
something that we as people in education
really benefited seeing that he's made a
difference so
so i'm just here supporting um keeping
the pool open
and um i know these pool committee won't
be there forever
um they're not getting any younger some
of them sandra sorry about that but um
you know like but i think they've got
their heart is in bluff and they want
the pool to keep going and i think i'm
here to just
totally support um what bluff's doing
and keeping i think options to keep kids
active i think
probably our kids nothing against them
but they are a little inactive
probably not the fittest units you'll
ever meet in your life but that's
something we're trying to work on at the
school as well to try and build up that
self belief
about them as well and i think swimming
is one thing that helps them so
thank you for your time i never been
here before so it's exciting
so far so good jeff hey look as as an
educator how
difficult is it logistically to to
organize those
those bus trips now so if you don't have
a pool
uh that you can walk around the corner
to and you've got to travel to in
cargo well probably for us uh darren
it's um
yeah the cost of it as well like we'd
have to pay for buses like i know
um by the time you paid buses for we've
got six we're 130 kids at school and
we've got you know there's another
school with about 30 kids there as well
um and it takes away your whole day as
well so you know like at the moment
you know you're taking away like every
class gets 10 swimming lessons
um per year as well as trying to use it
for other things um so
it just takes away from the education as
well if we have to drive to him for
cargo nothing is invocable but you know
it's 30 minutes and
by the time i swim and get back like at
the moment we use afternoons for
sessions
um so they go just after lunchtime and
they finish by the end of the day so you
reclass
it's not that much disruption really
compared to what what it could be to be
honest though so
yeah thanks jeff councillor lewis thank
you chair
jeff just a quick question do the staff
of the school actually do the the
swimming instruction
yes they do yes i know that's up to this
up here i wanted to use it yeah we'd
love to have uh
yeah and we're lucky enough as we've got
people in the community as well who come
and support us
through the swimming club and parents we
probably don't have
swimming instructors in bluff as some
other areas do so we're
we're lucky but we want to add to that
as well through hopefully through reap i
know they
touch on bluff as well that's something
we're working on as well graham so yes
councillor lush jeff can what is the
bluff community able to access
icc um ilt swim coaching is that
something
no no we're not because we haven't got
the because we're out of the area
yeah yeah so we're at the area yes is it
as strict as
is it as prescriptive as that because
we're out of the area we can't do it
yeah yes we're at the area
yeah so it's been working yeah where's
the love
okay
it's an issue that you can raise with
the invercargill licensing trust
themselves some of their schemes they
have gone outside of the area but it's
not something that
sits with us councillor kid
not a question but it might be to help i
believe the ilt
and the city council just recently have
been
in in discussions regarding
putting on a service bus service to
splash palace for swimming lessons and
that came from the head lady at the ilt
and a staff member here well it hasn't
hurt anyone
and we're in an open meeting since
probably
do you have any idea it's on the same
thing that daryl was asking a minute ago
is there a percentage of children that
wouldn't be able to come to invercargill
to casually swim and i'm presuming that
all the children in bluff casually swim
as well
but how many of those that casually swim
in bluff wouldn't be able to probably
come to indica would you have any rough
idea about that well i suppose
what what we do as a school we we do
pretty well um there's been some good
investments in the past in our school
and things like that so
we don't let kids miss out at bluff
school so you know like nobody misses
out and things but
i mean if there's no pull and bluff oh
how many kids would you like
all together i suggest you'll lose a lot
of people stay in bluff
that's my general you know like there's
a bit of old school there nothing
against bluff but
like people use the foursquare to do
this shopping so a lot of families stay
in bluff
um so it's sort of i would say you'll
lose a large percentage of kids who do
swim
and somewhere to start as well like i
think that's what we've seen is these
kids are starting in bluff
and now they're building up the top ones
we want to be swimmers but as well as
someone said before i think it's a life
skill as well that they need round water
and things like that like
a lot of our kids unfortunately jump off
wolves
or they jump off rocks on the corner of
you know and you know for us
you know we freak out but they need that
skill to be able to swim to survive as
well because you can't
you know kids unfortunately you can't
stop them jumping off wolves and things
like that but
they do it and um that's part of bluff
really so yeah
thank thank you councillor soper
thanks mr chair jeff are you um
feeling or could you say whether or not
you think
families will definitely use the pool
more
including the families of your students
if there is the keyless
key entry option
i probably cannot say but i think you
know you will get more people using it
um
but it's just will it be looked after as
well um you know by having that you know
you
don't have people in charge of a pool
and you know you let people come at any
time or things like that it's monitored
so it's closed at certain times so i
mean it's just
yeah things like that i suppose and
that's yeah and i think you know like if
you take the money away and you've got a
call committee who has to run it
and then those people move along um
unfortunately you might
lose that pool i know the costs of when
i heard about the cost that last money
went to and things like that are really
expensive
so it's probably just um you know i
think people would use it if it was
advertised right and things like that so
yeah you haven't had experience in your
teaching career of any of the
um rural schools that have a school
community pool at the moment no
no i do work at lockheed wind and have a
pool there but we we had to go
travel different places to make it work
like for example um like our little kids
we used to use winton pool
but it's too deep the winter pool for
the younger kids so we used macarea with
something that was a cost to the school
but it was a safety thing as well
thank you
councillor lewis good question chief i
may jeff health and safety issues have
you had
a care operation what security
monitoring of different age groups that
could get into trouble
do you think might what i'm trying to
ask what sort of health and safety
issues do you think could
arise if there was uh ready availability
to anybody
who had access to a swipe card for
example
yeah i suppose it's where whether
whether health and safety lies growing
with that day like yeah um
if someone does drown and you know does
it go in the pool committee or does it
go on
who's the owner that's that's probably a
very important thing as well because
as much as you might have a key and a
parent can use it to get them in
some of the kids will go in by
themselves so that's that's probably the
hard thing with the key and how you
manage that would be
the tough question but i suppose other
schools other places do it yes i'm not
i'm not aware with the whole system so
i'm just asking of you thanks very much
no further questions thanks jeff you
made it thanks for making the submission
and for coming in this afternoon
thanks for your time mate carolyn
all right so we're just going to enable
technology
um
go to carolyn it's the infico city
council calling how are you this
afternoon
oh very well thank you um yes
hello this is this is a new process for
us
i'm just making a bottle oh okay
i'll give you a moment we don't want to
go we don't want the catastrophe i'll
just go to the quite a room sorry i
thought i could get a minute
before i like your optimism
there we go carolyn thank you very much
for
making a submission uh we've got all the
counsellors present we've all had a
chance to read through it but
essentially you've got the
uh the next 10 minutes to speak to it um
and if you want to you know leave a bit
of time before your 10 minutes is up to
to make yourself available for any
questions that counselors may have
we've had a couple of people just ahead
of you who've been talking about the
bluff swing pool which of course is at
the the center of your submission but
essentially
it's over to you to to share your
thoughts and and opinions with us from
now
right thank you very much whanau
good everybody um i have not
long moved to bluff about four years ago
but
um i've found that i've been used i've
used the pools and i've found that it's
over the years it's a great um great
little pool
um and my daughter and i have been
um well my daughter particularly helps
with the swimming and that
and i think having the bluff pool there
is actually great for the community
because families don't have to travel
into town
and you kind of you know and a lot of
the um
the swimming clubs and their swimming
lessons in town start
if i can remember rightly from three
onwards
and you have school finishing and things
like that and so you need to allow for
like
a good two hours to get there and
swim pre-open and come back
but also you said we had a pool here in
town
or here in bluff if we kept it open not
just through
summer but all year round because
um winter time
i think is also a really good time to
have a pool open i used to live in
auckland and we lived at the pools
because you know it was warm warm water
and it was just something extra for the
young ones
to do for my you know short children to
do
um also i thought um having the pool
as well as an incentive for tourists
that come
through bluffs you can't always go for a
dip
in the ocean so just having
a pool a community pool where they can
drive to and because bluff's not such a
you know it's
not so big they can just veer off to the
right and up the hill two blocks up
there
um and i say this because when i was in
waiu on holiday one time during the
winter
um i was messing up the mountain we
thought right we'll go down to the local
pool
which we did in winter and it was um
you know inside heatos and i just that's
what sort of
they gave me the idea of that um and
also
um for like the likes of me i work eight
to five
um and so
you know going for a swim um before work
um you know you'll be able to
you know i have gone to for a swim and
then being able to shower and then come
straight to work
whereas if we didn't have a pool and
that opportunity for that
um i'd have to allow like an hour and a
half two hours
to get to town have a swim get changed
and drive back um yeah and it's just
also
when the children are old enough like
round pre-teens
and because the human unity is quite
close and everyone knows each other
um they're actually able to take
themselves
to the pool um was that you know with
that safety and
assuredness knowing that um
that they can swim
without parental supervision you know
over a certain age
um yeah i don't know what else
to say for you carol i'll i'll ask a
question i asked
yeah of an earlier submitter if there's
additional funds
required um that are expected from
council do you think it's fair for that
funding to come from a targeted rate for
the
residents of bluff
a targeted what was that so it's it's an
additional rate that only the residents
of bluff would pay
shed in amongst the bluff community pay
that
you pay a a rate along with everybody
else for the swimming pool and for cargo
yes
and and for the addition of their
current grant that's given
so do you re are you saying that the
additional
grant is going to be separate to the
what the
right of what was on our right now what
i was asking is
do you think it would be fair if there
was additional funding to be provided
for that to be a targeted rate on bluff
or alternatively
something that the whole city should
carry it's the whole thing it's just
that he should carry
because it isn't last part of him don't
we fall under that umbrella
i mean i think yeah
doesn't bluff fall under the
invercargill city council
so when you say that targeted rate and
you mean targeted
and put on to our reigns separate
from the infracargo city pool is that
what you're saying
yes no i don't think it should be i
think it should be included in the
i think it should whatever is in there
pull for the pool for the invercargill
city pool
i think bluff should come into i don't
think it should bluff to be
targeted as a separate range
that's a question that i asked of
another submitter so i'm just asking it
counselors
open to other questions
no there are none oh there are
carolyn thank you very much for the
submission thanks
thanks for making the submission and for
speaking to us this afternoon obviously
you've got a busy afternoon
oh i mentioned my lunch break now so
i've got any more
i can i've got 15 minutes
yeah we haven't um
i'd love to spend 15 minutes with the
council thanks currently for the office
offer carolyn but we'll get behind
thank you very much
jamie
my name is jamie lemali and i'm here
today to
speak on behalf speak on behalf of the
bluff swimming club
um and it's bluff community in hope of
encouraging the invicable city council
to continue providing annual operating
funds and support to
our bluff swimming club bluff is a small
community
surrounded by the rough and often
treacherous vivo strait
we're a community of fishing and
oystering
and we are a community already short of
opportunities for our children and
families
our swimming pool is a critical asset to
our community
for the past 15 years i have been part
of the bluff swimming club
as a parent a coach and as of 2019 the
president
season runs currently from october to
april two nights a week
and we currently have three hours a
night
with nine groups and about between 80
and 90 children registered
um both nights the full season
we solely run on volunteers and our club
has successfully been going since the
swimming pool was erected
uh and i believe it was actually prior
to that as well um
with carpooling to invercargill with
only a small amount of children
we have great community support with
many parents helping with lessons
by either being a parent help or
coaching fundraising and we're very
fortunate to have a lot of businesses
back us
swimming club is solely designed for our
children to learn to swim
and currently our biggest age group is
five to six year olds
these children are not only learning to
swim but also learning to be safe
in and around water which we cover with
water survival
nights throughout the season and usually
at the end of the season
being a port town surrounded by water
learning to swim and be safe around the
water is critical
as the children progress through the
club they focus on technique
and distance swimming before graduating
and finishing most of our swimming is
finished with a mild badge
and either one or all strokes
and a lot of parents put this on to the
children as
they have to finish the sea finish with
the club before they can
do this before they can finish and we
have a group of children that swim
competitively at both regional and
national levels
and we host three significant meets
throughout the season
southland white competitive meet a
southland wide have a ghost
swimming meet and our club champs at the
end of the season
most recent event we've seen eight 90
competitive swimmers from around
southland and otago
come to bluff for the day the pool is
also used for many other op
many other groups school swimming adult
fitness
rehabilitation and public sessions my
own children spend many hours at the
pool
as this is one of the only facilities in
available
for our young children in bluff to have
fun and enjoy their freedom
in a supervised all-weather venue
without a swimming pool
none of the above will be available for
our community and our children will miss
out on the great life skills of
learning to swim and will lack vital
water safety skills
which they need when they're swimming at
our beaches and
wharfs i believe there are so many
opportunities for our swimming pool to
grow
but more importantly i need i think it
needs to stay
open and be supported by our city
council and our community
thank you thanks jamie georgia do you
want to swing that microphone over
um
[Music]
firstly thank you for the opportunity to
be heard today
i think the bluff swimming pool plays a
crucial role in our life community
it gives our tamariki the opportunity to
thrive in swimming sports
and the opportunity to learn a life a
skill that could save their life in the
long run
um i am coming here as a parent i
currently have two children enrolled
with the bluff swimming club
they have been there for two years and
doing extremely well
and without the bluff swimming pool i
don't think this would be something that
they could do
myself and my husband work full time
and with that i don't think we'd have
the opportunity
to bring them into town it's just not
feasible for us
excuse me and i don't think it would be
feasible for at least 80 percent of our
whanau involved in the bluff swimming
club
to travel to town two times a week
um i strongly support and strongly
encourage the icc
to continue providing annual operating
funds to the bluff community swimming
pool
and there's no doubt in my mind that the
closure of this
pool will result in a huge decline of
our tamariki and bluff not swimming
and worst case scenario lead to a death
in te arau kiwa thank you good michelle
thank you very much for speaking to your
submission
counselors it's open to you to have
questions for jamie and michelle
council lewiston councillor super thank
you
thank you very much for enthralling the
presentation
you used to supervised venue
um jamie the previous submitters have
been talking about
key card entries would you be for that
or would you
prefer continued supervise i mean the
bluff swim club obviously is supervised
but for freedom for people out outside
normal swimming club hours
have uh keycard access would you be for
that
um not for children alone no um
if there was some ground some rules with
uh families
supervising their own children um yeah
that's fine
um just yeah not
with under there's twelves
yeah but i just wonder yeah
[Music]
um i think that's something that would
yes i just wondered how that would be
controlled i can't make comments but i'm
just asking questions about how
how well do you think that would be
supervised in the general public um i
think there will be
one question i think with the right
criteria put in place before this
happened
it would be it would be a good thing
thank you thank you thank you councillor
sopher
thanks mr chair my question was similar
i was going to ask you both if you
thought
a swipeless entry would increase the
usage of the pool
so if you've got any other comments on
that personally for me yes it would
increase
i mean that means that would allow my
husband who
also was a national representative for
swimming
still holds records in invercargill to
actually get back in the pool
before you know work
and i think we would use it more
personally as a family
more often thank you
thank you other questions
dorana thank you very much for taking
the time to come in and present to us
this afternoon
well done thank you
ian
welcome along
so just to draw councillors attention to
the fact that there are two submissions
here one that ends made personally one
on behalf of the
uh community pool trust so i'll just
make like a clarification there i didn't
actually ask to request on my personal
submission my um
okay so i'm just here for the bluff one
focus here is the pool thank you
yeah so it just must be a mix up there i
think i would bore you a little bit with
my uh
other personal opinions about things but
bluff is the focus um and that's why i'm
involved with the bluff trust the bluff
swimming pool
trust is because of a shared passion
that bluff has for the pool
um so i'd like to thank my fellow some
others here
um some brilliant words there jamie
michelle thank you
um firstly i'd like to thank the city
council for
the past nine years of funding that the
bluffpaw has had
has allowed the pool to keep operating
and uh i don't know how many hundreds of
kids have gone through their since but
lots um so that's been really
appreciated
um reasons to keep the pool
um children is the biggest
item that we need to keep the pool for
um when their children need to lead
learn to swim um all everybody in bluff
lives and plays and works around the
water um
being able to swim is critical um
and i and that goes without saying for
the whole new zealand but
especially for bluff um the school
swimming
um both schools in bluff use the pool um
for their swimming curriculum
and um without that there would be
substantial cost
and time loss to those children
in their learning stage of life
so then they need to have a pool and
bluff to learn to swim
um we also need to keep our older
children
active their youth um this
bluff is quite limited on what it has
for youth
and the swimming pool is a critical
place for those um
used to go um we want to keep them
active there's there's a real push in
new zealand for active communities and
there's a lot of funding around vector
community communities too so
we need to push for that um
uh also um accessed for to the pool for
our seniors
um we have a strong core of seniors that
use support as part of their
daily routine being active in in the
older years is really important
um uh so let's get to the other side of
50 i start feeling that
as well um it helps with many things
fitness
bone density osteoporosis there's all
sorts of things i won't get taken
over there because i don't know a lot
about it but um
one one item that that i think is that
this
council should consider is it actually
keeping the pool open provides the city
council with future
options around pools um i note in the
ltp that
the tail end of the ltp there's um eight
million dollars
talked about for us another poll right
in fukugo city
we already have one city council's got
the one in bluff
it's just maybe not thought through
cleverly enough
or um it may want to be attractive
enough to draw
and become people's health but i think
there's a strong opportunity to
um utilize tight time frames at the city
count at the splash palace that could be
used at bluff um things like dive clubs
or
maybe a dive club can't get in at 8
o'clock at night when it's
busy doing swim club stuff at space
palace well they could
head to bluff um many of you probably
don't know the bluff pool but it is a
very good asset it's a competition pool
25 metres
good depth it's it's a brilliant
brilliant pull um
many other clubs and groups use the pool
um you've heard from the swim club
um i've been involved with traq with sea
scouts and
we used the pool widely as well
and the swimmers that come out of bluff
are brilliant swimmers we have
several swimmers now that are competing
nationally and regionally um
tiara kira the current holders of the
intermediate
swim trophy for for the national sea
scouts and that's purely because of the
bluff swimming pool
and work done previously on with the
swim club
um though we mentioned earlier about the
future of bluff being bright well while
it is there's certainly
a real swing going on at the moment um
with i say this quite often but bluff is
run by the mothers
and it's so true and they're at the
moment there's a whole
tight core of bluff mothers driving
their kids to be active
and doing new and different things and
so
the pool is a key part of that
so the part of their submission is
around trying to actually save some
costs from the current
funding model that we've got and part of
the thinking there
is to provide um as well as open
sessions which are staffed
but to also provide um a keyless entry
a key entry sorry um now
there's a there's a great deal of
thought that has to be put into that
um we're only really the front end of it
but our current thinking is that
um we will be able to provide a
membership to the pool
that provides a family with a key and
to have that key they would have to be
go through an induction process they'd
have to
go through the entire list of what they
can and can't do the shells and shell
knots
um safety briefings the whole lot um
and we feel that we could manage it
that way in a safe manner we do have a
request that we can run a trial um
you're probably aware that the 180 000
grant runs for one further year until
2022.
um we would like to put in place the key
system
this season but maintaining the current
grant
to trial the system just to confirm that
we can actually run
the pool as we think we can for a
reduced num reduced
orbiting operating cost
the budgets we put together at the
moment for that reduced cost is 120 000
per annum which provides a
significant saving um just
as an aside if we did have our grant
reduced i'd be very keen to see that
money still spend in bluff
um
the other the other reason we need the
confirmation of the operating
funds is to um so that we can seek
funding for
upgrades um so that we've had
discussions with the
ilt foundation and community trust of
southland and also lotteries about
funding and understandably they are not
interested in providing any funding
until we have our operating
funds resolved um just makes total sense
um so that's another key reason why we
want to
confirm this funding and for a good
period of time
and in our submission we've asked for 10
years again another 10 years
the full ltp um but also to have it
adjusted for inflation against the cpi
um and that gives us some surety at the
at the tail end of the ten years that
our
funding is going to cover the cost has
increased
um so that's yeah that's probably about
it i think
there's so many thanksgiving get some
questions in sorry so
if you're looking at having your current
operating grant maintained
and you're able to reduce your
objects down leaving 60k
would you be better to be putting that
away for
for capital expenditure if you kept it
if we kept it at the current level okay
if if we keep
at 180 thousand dollars per um per annum
we would be able to provide a
more improved so a better service um i
think that we would
i'm just probably speaking off the cuff
here a little bit um but
i would suggest that we would provide a
better service
but still achieve our grants via the
normal funding avenues
um we'd be better off using that money
to
increase our season maybe go into the
shoulders of season into the winter a
little bit
if we do our upgrade and get the funds
we need
our plant will be modern and efficient
and
easy to run um the building will have
good insulation
the ceilings won't drip with water all
those sorts of things will have a great
a great facility um that potentially we
could run into some winter months
and and still have keep your operating
costs down
yeah council again yeah thank you
thank you for that in um i suppose
heating would be one of your major costs
down there is that right
absolutely yes we have an electric
boiler at the moment effectively and
and electric um heating and ventilation
uh is there any more efficient way
that you could perhaps our current
heating and ventilation system is on its
last legs
so that's what prompted the whole start
of this about
two years ago was when we started
looking into replacing that system
so it needs replaced now it's in danger
of failing right
um and so a new system will be more
efficient because
heat pump technology all that sort of
thing and also um
i know knowledge knowledge has suggested
me that we really should be looking into
you know solar and um
heating as well which is definitely an
option we've got a nice
sloped roof that faces northwest
so with the opening of the hydro slides
at splash palace
do you think you may lose some of your
patronage from down there or
no uh totally different
client base um our children
um do not get the opportunity to say at
three o'clock in the afternoon i want to
go to the um splash palace
mum and dad aren't available my mum's
busy dad's working
mum's working um it just doesn't work
like that
yep
yes i was just wondering we faced a lot
of similar charges
problems and challenges nine years ago
what was the main difference between
the situation then and the situation now
uh i suppose the situation then was
the focus was entirely on keeping the
pool
open um
at that time that you know bluff felt
you know um that there's actually being
stripped away from us being taken office
um to the council's credit they've
agreed to fund it for these ten years
but now we have a
an even better opportunity to um
grow the numbers of children than to go
to the pool adults that go to the pool
by providing this this key system um
it's it's exciting because the um
we've got the chance to make it a
desirable place for
for local bluffies as well as some
picago city
people to attend the poem
thank you thanks sam no further
questions
thank you for your submission and thank
you for taking the time to come along
this afternoon thank you
uh from bluff to a maui
john
welcome to the meeting john please have
a seat
[Music]
um
good afternoon
my name is john collins i'm a resident
of omari
and my purpose here is to present a
petition
from 40 or maui residents and road users
asking for omari and mokumoko roads
to be sealed
the 40 named people include our mail
contractor who uses the road six days a
week
and ymca south who own and operate the
camp at
maui the rest are all genuine
adult road users who are residents
there are no miners or occasional
visitors on the list
the names represent about eighty-five
percent of the omaha community who were
approached
the bluff community board has provided a
letter of support as has the ymca
um i'm told that you have all
read or seen a copy of the petition and
the reasons why
we want the road sealed we're included
there
um extra to that
is a letter from lisa and stephen taylor
who live
on michael morgan road or maui listing
four separate incidents
that happened to them on the road all of
which
basically caused by the state of the
road um
and have been reported to the council
one of them was a battery terminal
coming off their vehicle
coming around the corner on michael
morkul road where the corrugations are
really bad
and it sounds a bit incredulous but
i can believe that that would happen
sometimes it's really really bad there
we have to slow down to
10 kilometers per hour or less to get
around there without
jumping off the road
um just further to that uh petition the
reasons given there i just wanted to
say a bit about um or maui is changing
and it's one of the hidden gems of the
icc area
it's a beautiful place north facing
beach
it's being discovered
the community is growing new houses are
being built
sections are being cleared for sale and
existing houses
are being upgraded there's quite a bit
of money being spent out there
prices of houses and land are going up
and more people are living here and
using their road using the road
well maui is moving up market
residents use the road to go to work in
town
take kids to the school bus and
generally go about their business
residents families come in and out to
visit the trades people
delivery services mail gas etc
rubbish pickup and occasionally
emergency services
or maui the place has become incredibly
popular with beach goers and bush
walkers
summer days can see better than 50
vehicles parked in the car parks on the
beach
and on the roadside the stream of
vehicles coming and going continues all
day it's constant
even winter time see significant numbers
of people using the beach
in bushwalks people come in and out to
do voluntary work on track maintenance
and pest control
most of these people are icc rate payers
slash residence the ymca camp is often
busy
and sees a steady flow of school buses
visiting parents
support people and other camp users on
the road
some of these people are terrified by
the road it can be seen on their faces
as you drive past them
white knuckles on steering wheels
all of these activities are packed on
the road
the road is dangerous and dangerously
overused it is
well past its use by day and frankly
it's an embarrassment
it's third world and yes i have lived in
the third world
uh i believe it would cost between six
hundred thousand to a mill
to seal the four kilometers of or maui
and morgan
roads this is not a large sum for a
permanent
genuinely useful piece of infrastructure
there's an opportunity here for this
council to be seen to
be creating necessary worthwhile
infrastructure for a growing community
in a place that is a great recreational
destination
for many southland families i believe
that our road
is listed number five on a list of roads
to be sealed
um well we want to be bumped up to
number one priority
while this presentation is supported by
a large majority of all maui residents
there still needs to be consultation on
how the village is managed
that's the road in the village my
personal preference
and i'm only speaking for myself here is
is to have a 30 kilometer
per hour speed limit from just east of
the ymca camp
coupled with speed control device
devices such as speed humps
or chicanes
we already have a facebook group running
it's called fix or maori road that could
be
a good place to start consultation
with the people who live in o'malley
that's all i've got to say thank you
very much for listening
thanks john councillors it's over here
for questions
councillor clark then councillor lewis
you think uh john
just a couple quick things here for um i
got the cost
uh how many houses how many houses down
in the village
probably close to 40 now okay thank you
and you mentioned that the the length of
the road and i i missed it so if you
just
it's roughly four kilometers
yep thank you councillor lewis thank you
john an ongoing problem the
road maintenance how frequently do you
see a grader down there
how frequently do you see a grader doing
any uh remedial work down there because
i believe
some of those oh sorry i won't comment i
just if you can answer my question
please
um we're constantly putting in requests
for service
um i put one in 10 days ago it hasn't
happened yet
um the road is appalling at the moment
and one thing i did forget to say i did
miss out of there was that
when it rains heavily which it did
through last night
and the sides of the roads just get
washed out which means there's even less
room to move over
on hillcrest thank you that was the next
question i was going to ask but thanks
for answering that
okay thanks john thanks john councillor
lush
so johnny is there a group of in maui
that don't want the road sealed that
have
approached me and said that they want
the road remediated but they don't want
it sealed because they don't want
the undesirable people arriving there is
that a concern
i had an involved conversation with
someone who said that a lot of the
community don't want the road sealed
because of
meth dealers and people arriving there
and that seemed to be quite a valid
concern
yeah um is there two groups is there a
split in the maui of what people want
uh there's several different groups on
maui
but this um this group is
40 names is a large majority okay and as
i said
around i worked at the maths about 85
percent of the people that who were
approached
um agreed and signed
um there were some people that weren't
approached for various reasons
and there were some people who didn't
want to sign for various reasons
[Music]
the the reason that you've seen is
i have heard that said but i don't
believe that
it's any different will be any different
if the road was sealed to what it is now
i mean we have people um
charging around down there at night
particularly on the beach
um doing wheelies in the car park
um it's no different
so you don't see down you don't see a
downside to it being sealed
not really no okay thanks
councillor pottinger thank you chair
john just looking at the
map to give me an insight
so the the main straight but coming off
state highway one you go past several
gravel pits
yes that must be commercially used and
then you do that
real hard right all the way down to the
community so that road that first
road is it in worse condition than the
other because of there obviously must be
heavy trucks
um for servicing the gravel pits is that
the same condition is that
straight road that takes you all the way
in to a maui is that the same condition
which is tar sealed
that's tucson yes
right okay so i've got you right so
that's a long straight bit
yes right right and so the
the degradation of this road i mean
this is the first time i've sort of
heard it in 11 years on council i'm just
wondering
is it just been one of those annoying
things you've tolerated
and it's just or no the actual
maintenance dropped off on it all
no maintenance hasn't dropped off or not
um it's just
been used by a lot more people right and
that's cool
the beach has become increasingly
popular incredibly popular but there's
more people living there more people
coming in and out more residents
it's just being used more and more
that's cool let's answer the question
thanks
from my recollection i think there was
one other previous approach to council
to have the road sealed as well
but i can recall thank you any further
questions
if not thank you for your submission for
the petition and uh for the letters of
support that you've presented in it
cheers
christ
um
welcome along chris you're familiar with
the uh with the procedure for
for a hearing thank you yes i am i've
come with two hats today
mr chairman um one friends of the museum
which i had to put in as a late entry
because
the survey monkey wouldn't let me do a
second survey a
second submission but it chimes in with
what i've written as a
as a citizen because it's
it mainly focuses on retaining the
location of the museum where it is
and um the shape of the museum is an
iconic shape
so if you could just take that as red
it's somewhere i think gemma
took a copy of it but i didn't get one
back but it doesn't really matter
because that's what
all it was um
i've been part of this infrastructure
for
75 years so i think i have a little bit
of knowledge about this wonderful city i
have written on the trams that were
still around in the 1950s i think it was
i was only a little
so i do have a stake in the city and i
have also read
jane jacobs life and death of great
american cities which when i spoke to
my submission about the center of town
um had a very positive response from a
young man who was
thrilled that somebody had actually read
it so i do speak for
a bit of background knowledge both um
in terms of living here and um working
here and also as a
as a now uh so person who comes in to
town from lumsen under arduous
conditions today
to be part of what the city has to offer
and the comments about the city center
i'm a bit bit
fruitful about that because i was part
of the group that was supposedly
consulted about the inner city plan
i came with my forest and bird hat on uh
had lots of good ideas having recently
experienced what happens in a
one-and-a-half million
city in called vienna and also as a
person who uses the foot powers on the
streets
um for the last 60 plus years
so i that's why i'm grumpy about
what you've done with the city centre
plan um and as a driver
and as a person who uses these areas i
need a simple coherent plan along the
lines of what we have now
but it can be vastly improved with
the right sort of plantings color in the
buildings and verandas
once upon a time they were mandatory now
they seem to be
it's fairly haphazard but i do urge you
to look at
the reality of needing verandas to get
from one shop to another we're not all
going to be um
buying things from the mall i can assure
you of that
i've given you some ideas i have plenty
of other ones
and i'm still grumpy about the loss of a
perfect playground area
which would have been in the center of
the retail cbd uh
great for families and shoppers
dad's looking after the kids while mum
goes shopping
something like the margaret maher
playground would have fitted perfectly
in the area
which is now lost to a car park and the
irony is not lost on me either
now i will go to the southern museum in
art gallery of course i'm terribly
cleaning up because i go back to right
right back to mr mckenzie and russell
beck in terms of
visiting my favorite museum um
the friends are still are involved now
with looking at the future of the museum
and as a smag member i
i also am part of that but i'm sure the
wider community are just waiting
to be asked what their thoughts are
why i'm keen on in the interim looking
at some of the
heritage buildings that this council
owns is that you have some golden
opportunities
to showcase what can be done with
adaptive reuse of
buildings that are presently being
allowed to be demolished by neglect
and i know the mayor was very fretful
and upset about what was happening to
the kingston flyer
and he of course is now thrilled i'm
sure to know that the kingston flyer is
now alive and well and living
back on the railway line but there's two
it's too easy to pull down
uh heritage buildings under the pretext
that they're unsafe and
and unhygienic that's a cop-out and i
would like to think that the
council would actually look at the
buildings they own just down by the
railway station and there are a couple
of other buildings that
are very high on many people's lists
should be refurbished and those are the
two
that are presently owned by the hospital
um next to mcdonald's they have such
a potential for uh new use
not least as showcases for those
collections that
we know probably won't be housed able to
be
housed in the museum uh for a long time
and so they could be like to to wakahui
who we are put into those buildings and
um
showcase two and because and and
visitors
because this we've got some very special
collections at the
um at the museum presently languishing
because of
our lost impetus um and i've no
i did talk about that building being a
shining example of what you can do and
this so i'd like to think that we can be
but much more creative about what we do
with the
collections in the meantime and you've
got all the rest of my
things here um
can i just put in a couple of comments
the nzta have been very remiss
in probably funding our main roads
and that's why i put in about the ones
coming through the um city
i'm having this i've taken five years
for the nzta to shift a couple of signs
still haven't got it right so i'm very
not very happy about them so
um i think they should be really
approached it's not a subsidy
throat user charges which i pay some and
i think it's
it's a proper they have the say so they
should pay about what happens to those
two main arteries
and the other thing is to look at the
water supply for the future i
understand that there is a
a
what would you call it you're looking at
the estuary
aquifer as a means of taking the
pressure off bank's home in the
lower right area when it's dry
a long time ago talk was of um
getting in tanks for every building in
invercargill
that would take the pressure off the
euretia and breaks home it would also
provide you with
grey water uses which are the first
things to go when it when there's a
drought
and i think that that would be well
worth looking at and i'll be happy to be
work with somebody to do that
and i hope you get involved with kings
bend
i suspect it's going to be one hell of a
fight
and i would like to think that you and
the recycling center
have a really important role in playing
in the future around what i talk about
in
reuse recycling urban mining composting
and base materials for other uses
so i wish you well in that i hope that
nobody will will take up the cudgels
on our behalf and on the path of
southland and that anyone else who's
keen on that
will do the same i didn't talk anything
about rates apart from the fact that i
mentioned
in southern district council one that
people have gone through a pretty
pretty horrendous time with covert 19
and still haven't
um come out of it yet and i ask them to
look for to rates
a rates moratorium for this this year
until the world settles down um
post-vaccination
thanks chris it's open for questions
councillors councillor clark
thank you chair uh christine just wanted
to wear your hat of friends of the
museum
um i heard what you was reflecting on
that we could use some of our heritage
buildings
to display art and other things while we
deal with the museum
issue what i'd be interested to know is
what your organization friends of the
museum
feels about the proposal one of the
proposals on the long term plan
around the 52 million and five year
five and a half year project um we
haven't gotten that far we've had wayne
coming to talk to us about
all the various uh options and also he's
taken some of us around
inside the museum so we could look look
for ourselves at the
interior which is a fairly sobering
exercise i don't think we can talk money
at this stage nobody i think we really
have to look at
the architects the plans and um you
could put a round figure on it perhaps
as a start of 30 million
that seems to be quite a a good start um
laminated timber buildings we've been
discussing with wayne
i have anyway there are lots of options
but i think it's too soon to
actually pick a number apart from making
it modest
in initial stages and then working from
there as i say
bells and whistles later let's get it um
back to where we we can actually go in
again and
and enjoy what it has to offer
councillor pottinger oh hi christine hi
um
you mentioned here that you wish to
retain the pyramid shape
yes now can you explain
why you would do that i'm just it's just
purely from a
from a point of view that it's not not a
most practical shape of
fitting things into corners and straight
walls against walls and things like that
and if it had been designed originally
as a cube
would you have wanted to retain the cube
so are you trying to retain something
that
that's become iconic or you
just think that the pyramid is a
wonderful design i think it's becoming
iconic i also think that i'd like to be
certain i'd like like liverpool would be
third on the list
after the um um
pyramids at giza and the louvre in the
vicargo
why not let's think positively about
what what
the calgary has to offer the most
southern southernmost
pyramid in the world so the other
alternative
would you be happy if for a chance
a new design took on board
a component like the louvre perimeters
just outside you know it's a feature
outside uh or would you want to be in
boots and all
for a total perimeter gumboots and all
actually
no i think i think again it's it has to
come up to practicality
and um and features but i do
think there's a general consensus out
there the iconic shape
in some form has to remain but but in
what final form
um we've got a lot of talking to you
about that yet okay
thank you thanks christine and thanks
once again for your passion
and uh for going to the effort of making
your submission and sharing your
thoughts with us
i appreciate the opportunity thank you
very much
gloria
on behalf of the bluff community board
welcome everybody
worship the mayor councillors
um bluff community board have put this
um submission in um we think is
relevant for bluff um because when
so many um
motorhomes that come in two bluff now um
larger and they
well i know we have one the camping
ground in bluff
but our the buses aren't
unable to get in there
um because it's a situation
where it is put and because we're
um the five wheelers
um they can't get into there
and plus um there's larger
caravans that carry their waste water
and grey water and they can't maneuver
properly
so we're looking at
putting um
that another dump station be put into
bluff um
because we're um
the because
we're getting more coming to bluff now
campervans because we've got um
sterling point we're finding it hard for
them to move around there
and we find that
the facilities aren't adequate
for them we look um
possibly sites suggested could be near
the bluff sign
or coming into bluff or at ocean beach
or plus we've got our golf park round
there
um could be ideal places for
um to put another dump station
um the other application we were looking
at
was another toilet
we've got a playground that's frequently
used by
children and there's no toilet
they are going um to the
they are going in amongst the trees and
urinating
which is not very hygienic
and plus that that
um toilet was moved by the council
a long time back and was moved up to the
um by the service centre so
really we do need that third toilet
this one round that sterling point but
who
um you can't expect a child
to go from sterling from the playground
where the town hall is either up to the
server center or around a sterling point
it's impossible
plus we have morrison's beach just a
minutes
walk and they're going in behind the
the trees that are there um
i think we need to look at another
toilet
thanks gloria how long ago did that the
the excellent
shift from outside the old town hall
down to the surf center
when was there um when they do they when
they did the
alterations to the the
um the main part of yeah so quite some
down
so it's been free been gone for a
while thanks yeah councillor lush
um yes great idea about the toilet they
need that certainly for the schools
morrison's speech and that's often used
would it not be a better idea to
put the toilet where the playground is
now
and move the playground across the road
to the proposed site that you're talking
about for the toilet because the
playground
despite some of the submitters saying
it's world-class is
terribly cold and not in a very good
place i mean after two or three o'clock
it's in shade
and it's a i can't imagine why anyone
ever built the
playground there would be possible to
put the playground
on the other side of the road
so so the toilets in that ground we're
next to the lighthouse cafe because
that would be better wouldn't it no
you've got
um all the pipes and everything are
there
where the town hall is where the old one
was
would have been better to put it back
where
the toilet was in the first place than
um cutting the playground smaller
so you think you think the playground
should remain where it is
i agree despite the fact that it's in
shade all day
yep it is fine where it is
okay thank you any further questions
councillor lewis
thank you chair gloria in about 2011 i
think the new zealand motor club
association made a presentation to the
bluff community board
and at that time they were talking about
helping funding have you been in contact
with new zealand
home association um no i haven't
okay because i think you you mentioned
the bluff
sorry the ocean beach area private land
um
how would they feel about that because i
think the turning circle there might be
better than down the sterling point for
the planet yeah
i think if we negotiated with them talk
with them
i'm sure that they would come to an
agreement
thank you would you be interested in
asking
the chair of the bluff community board
to enter into negotiations with with
them
to see how they felt about it i
certainly would
thanks gloria further questions for
gloria
if not thanks gloria as always we value
your presence and your input on this
instance on behalf
of the bluff community board thank you
very much
councillors here's where uh we adjourn
this hearing for this afternoon and it
reconvenes tomorrow morning at nine
promptly uh we will take a short break
and open with the performance policy and
partnerships committee
at three just a reminder that we will
adjourn that meeting if we're not
already finished
for the extraordinary infrastructural
services meeting at four o'clock and if
we have any business to
finish for ppp we'll come back and do
that after
infrastructure thanks we are adjourned
oh no i was trying to work out left
where
you